Facebook everyone knows that are an evil
corporatist snake that violates our
privacy
sidenote please like our fanpage for all
the updates on my views and our non
organic energy suppositories
like I was saying I'm not a hypocrite
but you know who is the mainstream media
they don't care about substance just
like every woman I date they're obsessed
with performance Facebook's Mark
Zuckerberg about to testify for the
first time before Congress is so awkward
he's awkward on stage he could be a
little bit awkward reportedly he's
taking a crash course in humility and
charm Zuckerberg don't listen to these
clowns because no one can teach you
charisma the way I can because my
milkshake brings all the boys to the
yard
and occasionally the police so
Zuckerberg finally showed up to testify
for the Senate today and he gave the
commanding performance of a lukewarm
puddle we didn't take a broad enough
view of our responsibility and that was
a big mistake we have made a lot of
mistakes in running the company it was
clearly a mistake we made mistakes it
was my mistake and I'm sorry
Oh bad job man when you admit a mistake
you make an ass out of you and me that's
common knowledge look duck you've been
publicly apologizing for one Facebook
thing or another for the past 14 years
and all of you gotten is this lousy
t-shirt
you don't need coaching and humility you
need opposition citizen journalists Josh
sharp and Aaron Jackson give it up ever
you Thank You Jordan duck needs to stop
apologizing sorry is for limp-dick board
games and Democratic senators from
Minnesota DC and 2018 is about whipping
out your ego and acting like a
borderline maniac you know being
presidential so we're here to coach
Tucker Berg on how to avoid apologies
altogether so he can dominate his
congressional hearing tomorrow Jordan
you're gonna play the congressman and
will portray Zuckerberg No got it okay
aren't you responsible for allowing your
didn't get into it you're a congressman
oh maybe one from Massachusetts eating
child I trapped in Haven yard okay
aren't you responsible for allowing
companies to access massive troves of
user dollar that Cambridge analytic are
others that exploited
[Applause]
all right so this is what you do suck
good questions sir the data breach was
terrible and the blimps did it everyone
knows those eggheads love data so much
they want to take it to Burning Man and
get it pregnant by a bonfire so it'll
pump out even more data it was Obama and
Hillary they're living at a Planned
Parenthood in Los Angeles stealing your
data on their Anthony Weiner laptops
case closed we're Mark Zuckerberg oh
that was great
not apologizing by passing blame to lids
you never have to admit that Russian
trolls got our aunt's to organize all
lives matter rally literally all of our
on okay let's move on to another
approach shape uh how did you not come
on your Congress man damn right okay
where I do declare how did you not
inform 87 million Facebook you just back
into it
congressman 87 million users that's not
the number I had no in fact the number I
have from my research is zero yeah no
one was affected at all it's definitely
zero everyone's talking about how it's
zero I'm certainly talking about it's
all over my facebook newsfeed so it's
obviously right it seems like if you get
all the facts out there it's pretty hard
to tell which ones are the right ones
you can't get mad about reality if
you're not a hundred percent sure what
reality is anymore or a hundred and ten
percent which is the most you can have
see what I mean potent stuff let's see
last one only there mr. Chuck appeared
in Jordan Jordan
bold choice but I do hate it let's just
read the question because I was thinking
that too what are you doing to prevent
foreign actors from using Facebook to
influence our free elections here in
America okay as we've stated Facebook is
an idealistic and optimistic company
yeah you viagra chomping jack why dig a
hole to die in you were there sucking
bogey
Facebook is a nitrocharge dopamine
bursting money printing machine
and we're gonna suck in your eyeballs
slam it with ads and spit them out my
corn through a cob shucker your
farmville addicted troglodyte you'll
never quit Facebook you human crust whoa
I won't lie that is very unsettling yeah
admittedly being a huge dick is like the
blunt force object of political rhetoric
but it's very effective if you're
willing to get punched in the face I am
and anyone from that Fight Club who says
otherwise is a liar yes okay so that's
all sucks got to know to avoid
apologizing well there's also always the
UM classic elevator exit the elevator
exit right you can't answer the question
if you're on a different floor second
well what did anyone answer for anything
anymore in Trump's DC no one has to
Jordan study up suck the fight continues
[Music]